in the us we have the term moonshot it's
used to describe a project that could
have profound and far-reaching effects
but requires a monumental effort to be
made real
and that usually needs to happen in a
short period of time
it originates from nasa successfully
putting the first man on the moon in
1969
and thus winning the space race for all
mankind
imagines an alternate history where that
didn't happen
what if america's moonshot was only good
enough for second
place how would things have turned out
differently hey guys
pete here for all mankind which just
came back for what looks like a much
improved second season on apple tv plus
presents an alternate history where the
space race plays out differently the
soviet union being the first nation to
put a man on the moon
leads to some interesting ripple effects
in the show's alternate timeline
it's fun to speculate on the changes not
just in the space race or the
geopolitics of the cold war
but across the board the premise gives
the creators a chance to
reimagine the history we know while
sticking close to it
plenty of real world events play out the
same way but it also presents a great
opportunity to imagine a different
future as a warning this video will
include spoilers for the first
season and the time jump that happens
before season 2 gets started
while we don't actually see this as part
of the show the timeline of for all
mankind diverges from ours in january
1966.
sergey kovalev was a driving force
behind the soviet space
program and in our timeline he died from
complications
during a surgical procedure in the for
all mankind timeline
he survived that surgery and his
continued presence
helped propel the soviet space program
to victory in their race to put a man on
the moon
first against their cold war rival the
u.s
season one of the show opens with that
historic event on june 26
1969 the russian cosmonaut alexei
leonov takes the first steps on the moon
and plants the flag of the soviet union
this comes as a total surprise to nasa
who we learned later
probably could have pushed to land the
apollo 10 astronauts a month earlier
when they were there
while they were doing what amounted to a
dress rehearsal for a landing that was
planned for the next mission
in creating their timeline the show uses
a combination of fictional characters
mixed in with real ones we know from
history for example the original crew of
apollo 10 were switched out
with the fictional astronauts ed baldwin
and gordo stevens
with that being the central character in
the middle of a big
ensemble cast a few weeks after the
russians get there
apollo 11 completes its mission with
astronauts neil
armstrong and buzz aldrin becoming the
first americans to land on the moon
these are the same astronauts who were
on apollo 11 in our timeline but the
fact that they weren't the first to get
there
leads to drastic changes in the show the
soviet union stays in the race they keep
the space race going
in reality they never had a successful
manned mission to land on the moon
and after apollo 11 got there first the
space race in relation to the moon was
pretty much
over in the show the us is still looking
for a victory and by early september
nasa is considering a permanent lunar
base
at the insistence of president nixon
that same month
just after apollo 12 launched the
soviets achieved another first by
putting the first woman
anastasia bellacoba on the moon on
september 16th
this is something that's never happened
in our timeline the soviets were first
in sending a woman
into space back in 1963 with the u.s
expanding its program to include women
in the 1980s
sending several women into space after
that but no women have been to the moon
the first plan to actually put a woman
on the moon in our timeline
is set for 2024 as a part of the artemis
program
another divergence happens at this time
when the nazi rocket engineer
werner von braun who was brought to the
us through
operation paperclip after world war ii
is pushed out of nasa due to new
revelations about his time
as a member of the ss the thing that
brought him down was the use of slave
labor from concentration camps for the
construction
of the v2 rockets this was something
that was known in our timeline
it actually happened and he did receive
a lot of criticism related to it but he
was never forced out of his position
all of the stuff that we learned about
in the late 60s
sets things up to move quickly in the
1970s
at the beginning of that year in the
show's timeline the nixon administration
pushes nasa to begin a training program
with 20 female astronaut candidates as i
mentioned this didn't happen
the u.s started taking applications for
women in the late 70s
years after the last trip to the moon
apollo 17
in 1972. in the show during january of
1970 we first start to see
friction between the us and the ussr in
relation to the outer space
treaty of 1967 the soviet premier
accused the nixon administration of
planning to include
missile installations to go along with
the new moon base that they're trying to
put together
later in march of 1970 attack spots what
he thinks might be ice on the surface of
the moon
this is something that doesn't happen in
our timeline until 2008 and it's made
possible because in the show they
continue
nasa's lunar orbiter project beyond the
five satellites we launched
the ice was discovered by lunar orbiter
number six
this means in april of that year when
apollo 13 goes back
on a mission to scout for sites for
potential lunar bases the scope of that
gets wider
it also means that later in july that
the us gets intelligence that suggests
at least one soviet cosmonaut was killed
in a crash while they were trying to
land habitation modules
also in our timeline apollo 13 never
made it to the moon they ran into
problems which made for a few
suspenseful days when people didn't know
if they were going to be able to make it
back to earth or not
a couple of months later in october
president nixon
starts to withdraw american troops from
vietnam
almost three years earlier than when
that happened in our timeline
in that same month the first four female
astronaut candidates are approved by
nasa
and become available for future missions
in 1971 we have two trips to the moon in
the show
at the end of january into february
apollo 14 goes and looks for
potential lunar base sites later in the
year in october
apollo 15 launches molly cobb becomes
the first american woman
to go to space they decide to change
their landing site to shackleton crater
in search of water and they're able to
find that when molly extracts some ice
from the bottom of the crater
in 1972 we have two more trips apollo 16
and apollo 17 both go back to the moon
and in november of that year richard
nixon
is defeated by ted kennedy which of
course didn't happen in our timeline so
kennedy becomes the 38th president
the show does inject at a point that the
incident at chappaquiddick never happens
in this timeline and it should be noted
that everything that happens in space
from here on out
is a complete divergence from our
timeline apollo 17
in 1972 was the us space program's last
manned mission to the moon
in the show after the election apollo 18
goes back to the moon
in the first half of 1973 apollo 19 and
apollo 20 both happen
and also in the show's timeline the
space shuttle and sea dragon programs
are both approved and in his state of
the union address
president kennedy vows that the ussr
won't beat the united states to mars
in october of 73 jamestown the first
american lunar base
lands on the surface of the moon near
shackleton crater
and it's occupied at first by the crew
of apollo 21.
in july of 1974 apollo 22
launches to replace the crew of apollo
21
at jamestown in august apollo 23
explodes on the launch pad that kills
the director of johnson space center
gene kranz as well as another 11 staff
members who worked at the launch pad
we also see the equal rights amendment
ratified when the state of illinois
becomes the 37th state to ratify it
so in the alternate timeline the
fictional astronauts
of the fictional apollo 22 are stuck at
the fictional
jamestown lunar base by this time the
soviets have their own lunar base that's
manned by three cosmonauts
and is located about eight miles away
from jamestown
in fictional politics kennedy still
pardons richard nixon for the watergate
break-in
and then he's hit with the scandal when
photographs of him
are surfaced where he's in compromising
positions
with one of his female white house
staffers because of the apollo 23
explosion
the 22 crew is there for much longer
than they should be
and gordo stephen starts to have a
mental breakdown when she realizes this
will
end his career astronaut danny poole
fakes an
injury so the two of them have to return
to earth leaving ed baldwin there by
himself
around the same time the american
astronauts find
evidence that the soviets are operating
near their shackleton mining operation
and ed is then ordered to surveil them
in december of 74
apollo 24 is launched to relieve ed from
jamestown but before they do their
translunar injection
they have a malfunction and their rocket
doesn't ignite
leaving them stranded at jamestown on
the surface
one of the russian cosmonauts shows up
and ed holds him captive
by this time apollo 25 is launched
trying to repair apollo 24 after
completing the operation
the rocket on apollo 24 fires
unexpectedly
and that kills astronaut harrison liu
and injures deke
slayton who ellen's able to get back
into the capsule
ed gets help from the russian cosmonaut
they're able to use the lunar module to
help apollo 24
and it's able to make it to the lunar
surface deke slayton dies of his
injuries and i guess it's worth
mentioning that he's based on a real
person
although obviously he didn't die in this
way
and ellen relieving ed at jamestown him
going back home that's the end of season
one
in 1975 the u.s were successful in
landing their first rover on mars as a
part of project biking
using a lander called hermes which was
protected by airbags
they were able to safely reach the
surface and deploy their robotic rover
which was named sojourner
in our timeline this didn't happen until
1997
with the pathfinder mission its rover
had the same name
and was the first wheeled vehicle to
ever explore another planet
in the in between time in 1976
ronald reagan is elected president of
the united states
defeating ted kennedy and this is four
years earlier than he became president
in our timeline at around that same time
the outer space
treaty is dissolved which means that
militarization of the moon is no longer
off the table
in 1977 the us has its first launch of
the sea dragon
which happens a year after the russians
had launched their first n3 rocket in
the show's timeline
the sea dragon continues in use it's
basically for heavy payloads
the first launch carried over a million
pounds of building supplies
and that included equipment and fuel for
the expansion of the jamestown base
in 1978 the camp david meeting between
the leaders of egypt and israel
is a failure that falls apart in the
show's timeline
in 1979 the soviets withdrawal from the
afghan
border and they never invade the country
in the show's timeline
this is likely related to their
prioritizing the space race
president reagan is able to bring home
the american hostages that were held in
iran
ending that crisis in just 92 days
in 1980 in the show john lennon survives
the assassination attempt that happened
to him in new york city
in real life of course he died there the
miracle on ice never happens
the soviet team defeats the americans at
the winter olympics at lake placid new
york
and reagan is re-elected as president
with a narrow margin of victory
in 1981 pope john paul ii actually dies
in his assassination attempt prince
charles marries
camilla instead of diana the reagan
administration decides not to bail out
the chrysler corporation with federal
money
and egyptian president sadat survives an
assassination
attempt so there's a weird trio of
assassination flip-flops
omar sadat and john lennon both survive
their attempts but pope john paul ii
dies
there's a couple other things that i'm
not sure exactly when they happen
the military starts their own space
shuttle program
and they launched their first shuttle in
august of 1981.
the other thing is that at some point
congress passes legislation
that makes it so that nasa can use
profits from things that they design
and put that right back into their own
budget rather than it going to the
federal government
so that incentivizes them and also makes
their budget bigger than it would
normally be
and finally in 1982 there's a crisis in
berlin an east german couple
try to flee into west berlin by scaling
the wall
they're chased by east german and soviet
forces
in a tank they're killed and that leads
to an exchange of small arms fire
and that leads to a tense standoff
between the east and west german border
guards
those are backed up by the soviet and
nato and u.s
forces and it went on for several hours
and dropoff the soviet premier
warned that this kind of thing showed
that the reagan administration was
approaching a dangerous red line of
nuclear war
and in that time the threat level was
escalated to defcon 4
and the u.s scrambled aircraft near the
soviet border
and that's pretty much all the major
changes we've seen so far
what's interesting is that we already
know there's a season three coming
it's already been ordered and the
creators have said that it's gonna
probably skip another 10 years
so at some point we're gonna see these
divergences turn into a different place
that we barely recognize
and if they can stick around for enough
seasons they'll eventually pass
us and we'll be speculating about a
future so i'm gonna leave it there
let me know what you think about the
alternate timeline which changes do you
like which ones would you have liked to
have seen
what do you hope to see in the future
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon